[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum internationalen
Frühschoppen in einer Woche in der es
einige internationale Begegnungen gab
Bundeskanzler Scholz war auf Blitzbesuch
in Washington bei seinem Amtskollegen
Joe Biden und das Treffen der G20
außenministerinnen und Außenminister in
Indien gegen ohne gemeinsame
Abschlusserklärung zu Ende insgesamt
scheinen die Fronten zwischen USA und
Europa auf der einen Seite und China und
Russland auf der anderen Seite weiter
verhärtet zu sein auf der Suche nach
Verbündeten Europa und die neue
Weltordnung das ist unser Thema heute
und ich freue mich es mit diesen Gästen
zu besprechen bei uns ist dass du da
David will sie ist Publizistin und
Direktorin des German Marshall fand in
Berlin und Elen kohl ist bei uns sie ist
Berlin Korrespondentin für französische
Medien und wir begrüßen zu Polizist und
Politikwissenschaftler der Universität
Bonn und herzlich willkommen Georg
Mascolo er ist Journalist und Autor bei
der Süddeutschen Zeitung
der Besuch von Bundeskanzler Scholz
dieses Wochenende der war ja
ungewöhnlich ohne Mitreisende
Journalisten ohne anschließende
Pressekonferenz ging es aus ihrer Sicht
eher darum dass man ein machtvolles
Zeichen gesetzt hat in einem gewissen
Timing vielleicht auch zu dem heute ja
beginnenden Volkskongress in China also
ich würde schon vermuten dass die beiden
sich nicht getroffen haben um dann nicht
tatsächlich auch über substanzielle
Dinge zu sprechen und ich glaube welche
das sind liegt auch wenn man wenig über
das Treffen weiß auf der Hand so wie
geht der Krieg in der Ukraine weiter wie
können Sicherheitsgarantien für die
Ukraine aussehen
muss man befürchten dass China darüber
werden wir sicher noch reden Russland
Waffen liefert aber dann gibt es ein
Element ist die ich genauso wie sie das
ist schon vor allem von Seiten von Olaf
Scholz eine regelrechte Demonstration
und die Demonstration heißt
wenn es wirklich wichtig wird dann reden
wir unter uns wir tun es ohne
Pressekonferenzen ohne Mitreisende
Journalisten ich glaube das ist ein
richtiges Symbol dass er hier einmal hat
setzen wollen ist er sagt es sind so
ernste und schwierige Fragen und ich
suche einen solchen Raum ich
demonstriere einen solchen Raum der
Vertraulichkeit
indem ich mich mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten zusammensetze und das ist ja
das ist ein ein geradezu demonstrativer
Akt gewesen ich würde jetzt allerdings
hoffen
dass wenn die Journalistinnen und
Journalisten auf dieser Seite und auch
auf der anderen Seite des Atlantik ihre
Arbeit machen wir mit der Zeit natürlich
auch erfahren werden was jedenfalls grob
die Richtung dieses Gesprächs gewesen
ist dann gehen wir mal auf die andere
Seite in dem Fall Frau David wie ist es
in den USA aufgenommen worden dieses
Gespräch ich stimme meistens so mit
Georg ich glaube das Meeting war wichtig
einfach beide Seiten ernsthaft zu
diskutieren über die weitere Schritte
für die Ukraine in Washington ist die
Zeiten wenn der begrüßt geworden aber
natürlich denkt man auch dass
Deutschland muss ein bisschen mehr Tempo
schenken wenn es geht um die Amerika
Ausrüstungen aber man weiß man hat
Geduld eigentlich hat die beiden
Regierung viel Rückendeckung an die an
Deutschland gegeben und es hat sich
ausgezahlt ich meine Nord Stream 2 ist
kein mehr ein Thema kein Thema mehr
Deutschland mag die zeitenbänder aber
auf Dauer muss man schon sagen dass die
Wunsche ist dass Deutschland auch ein
bisschen mehr Markt um ein besserer
Partner ein glaubwürdiger Partner auf
militärische Hinsicht auch dass damit
das entwickeln kann genau das war ja das
Thema im Vorfeld zu der Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer da gab es ja schon eine
gewisse Form der Irritation wir haben
sie es wahrgenommen oder wie ist es in
Frankreich auch aufgenommen worden
dieses Treffen gerade nachdem es ja
diese Irritation bezüglich der Lieferung
mit den Kampfpanzern gegeben hatte also
offiziell ist es so dass diese
deutschsprachigen Motor dort passiert
war jetzt eigentlich wieder auf guten
Weg ist also es gab ja zwei zwei 20 22
schon Irritation und Schwierigkeiten
aber wir haben im Januar unser 60 Jahre
Freundschaft groß gefeiert und offiziell
arbeiten wir jetzt zusammen und
interessant zu sehen ist als Scholz
jetzt in der USA geheizt ist war auch
macron in Afrika und gleichzeitig auch
diese diese Treffen der Außenministerien
in Indien also man sieht schon wenn man
an diesen narrativ glaubt dass
Deutschland Frankreich zusammen agieren
auf internationaler Ebene da hat man
schon ein europäischen
in Richtung mehrere Partner und und so
weiter ich glaube es ist den Franzosen
und insbesondere im französischen
Präsident sehr klar geworden in diesem
letzten 12 Monate wie wichtig dieser USA
makromatisch schon einige Partner
natürlich ruskiert vor einigen Jahren 20
19 war das als der gesagt hat die NATO
ist ihren Tod ähm das ist jetzt falsch
sehen wir auch die längste müllteiche
Bündnis der Welt oder Geschichte ist
wichtig für uns und wenn man sieht wie
Frankreich nicht entwickelt man spricht
nicht mehr von einer die Wichtigkeit
eine europäische Armee zum Beispiel
sondern er will diese europäische Teil
innerhalb der Natur
also kräftigen also wer Druck geben und
ich glaube da sieht man auch schon es
gab die zeitenwände es gibt immer noch
die zeitenwände hier aber Frankreich
entwickelt sich auch in diese Sache die
Frage ist inwiefern wir tatsächlich alle
zusammen ein strategische Denken
entwickelt können auf jeden Fall der
Titel unserer Sendung ist ja auch auf
der Suche nach Verbündeten und heute hat
ja der Volkskongress in China begonnen
und China hat erklärt im Vorfeld man
betrachtet Europa als umfassenden
strategischen Partner gleichzeitig hatte
China ja zuvor mal den USA vorgeworfen
Kriegstreiber Nummer eins in der Welt zu
sein wie angespannt ist dieses
Verhältnis China USA
sehr spannend mehr als spannende glaube
ich weil die Chinesen
haben das Gefühl dass
dass sie jetzt von der USA identifiziert
wurden sind als die der größte
hierausforderung Bedrohung für die USA
für die nationale Sicherheit und wenn
ist aus meiner Sicht sehen und deswegen
versucht man natürlich auch die
Politik der beiden Regierung zu
relativieren oder zu schwächen eine
Blockbildung zwischen Europa und der USA
hierbei zu führen und da hier unter dem
Aspekte beobachtete Peking sehr genau
was es schon ist und
beiden jetzt in den USA gesprochen hat
er niemand weiß das genau aber in der
chinesische Presse wird auch poliert
betrachtet
fast
eine Stunde
gesprächsvorführen das musst Du war
unglaubliche wichtige Dinge sein aber
was das ist weiß man nicht mehr hatte
natürlich
den Verdacht dass es darum geht die
sanktions
Politik oder Überlegungen die beiden
jetzt die Diskussionen gebracht haben
jetzt zu vertiefen und den europä zu
fragen ob Europa dabei sein könnte wenn
tatsächlich
Sanktionen Verhältnis werden von der USA
die Chinesin warten an Russland liefern
würde also sehr spannend Situation große
dass das
die die die
ist Kation das Potenzial ist sehr groß
hat sozusagen ein Teil dieses Treffens
das genau diese Spekulationen inwiefern
wurde über Sanktionen gesprochen ja so
ein bisschen einfach schon
klar machen soll wenn es tatsächlich
eine Waffenlieferung seitens China an
Russland gibt dann ist da ein
entschlossenes Handeln USA dass man
darüber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
spekulieren muss sondern es gibt eine
Fülle von öffentlichen Erklärungen
zuletzt Olaf Scholz auch bevor er nach
Washington gefahren ist im Deutschen
Bundestag und ich glaube das Signal an
die chinesischen Seite ist ganz klar
sein beginnen dieses
Überfalls auf die Ukraine läuft die
Diskussion ob im Grunde in dem Maße in
dem der Westen sich entscheidet
Hochtechnologie oder alles was für den
Bau von Waffen notwendig ist nicht mehr
nach Russland zu liefern ob so wie wir
es in anderen Bereichen auch sehen
Russland sich in Richtung China
orientieren wird da gibt es sagen immer
gemischte Signale und in den letzten
Wochen sind ganz offensichtlich
Informationen dazu gekommen die heißen
dass es Verhandlungen geben könnte ich
formuliere das hier im Konjunktiv
zwischen russischen Firmen und dem
Hersteller von Kamikaze Drohnen in China
und ich glaube dass die deutsche aber
vor allem auch die amerikanische Seite
sich entschlossen hat diese
Informationen so zu verwenden wie wir es
vor dem Angriffskrieg Russlands auch
gesehen haben es hat gehanddienst
Informationen werden eingesetzt wenn sie
da sind sie werden früh öffentlich
gemacht es wird gewarnt und nach
jetzigem Stand scheint das funktioniert
zu haben sage ich in aller Vorsicht aber
es gibt ein zweites Feld auf das hier
noch verweisen will
die USA und zwar seit vielen Jahren
drücken die Bundesregierung sowie viele
andere europäische Länder in der Frage
der technologischen Abhängigkeit von
China nicht den Fehler zu wiederholen
den sie im Bezug auf Rohstoffe vor allem
Gas und Öl in Bezug auf Russland
eingegangen sind das Thema hieß Huawei
wenn wir uns hier am Tisch erinnern
und ich erwarte dass auch die
Bundesregierung die obwohl entsprechende
Gesetze verabschiedet worden sind in
diesem Bereich dann doch eher hinhalten
agiert hat
hier jetzt richtig einen Gang
hochschalten wird und es klare Signale
geben wird das in der Frage welche
Technologie importieren wir noch aus
China und an welchen Stellen sagen wir
wir wollen den russischen den Fehler der
Abhängigkeit gegenüber Russland nicht
wiederholen das ist da klarere und
stärkere Signale der Europäer geben wird
und auch klare Signale der deutschen und
dass das auch etwas ist was beiden bei
Scholz eingefordert hat und einfordern
wird ist das tatsächlich dieser Druck
der jetzt auch ganz klar gemacht wird
Seiten der USA wenn China liefert dann
müsst ihr viel entschiedener und ganz
das was der Maske gerade geschildert hat
ganz direkt an unserer Seite stehen das
ist nicht eine Frage von jetzt ist es
schon ein Thema schon vor Jahren jetzt
sind die transistanische Beziehung genau
wie der gesagt hat vor cowert ein Thema
und ich denke wahrscheinlich mit dem
Gespräch es war nur eine Stunde aber die
zwei Punkte die wichtig sind
sind China dass man versteht dass
Deutschland hat viel Handel mit China
und man kann nicht am obernarkt alle
Handelsbeziehungen enden wie mit
Russland aber man muss aufpassen wegen
kritische Infrastruktur und im Falle von
Waffenlieferung an Russland was macht
man wird Europa auf seitens der USA und
andere demokratische
Länder zusammen sein wegen Sanktionen
oder gibt es diese Mittelweg und das hat
man schon gesehen das war gefährlich mit
Russland wandern durch Handel hat nicht
funktioniert das zweite Thema ich glaube
ist das 2 % ähm wie gesagt es gibt viele
Geduld für Deutschland über die Jahren
aber jetzt haben wir ein Punkt wo ich
glaube es gibt keinen mehr Spielraum
Deutschland muss jetzt diese zwei
Prozent Ziel erreichen sonst gibt's
keine Verständnis in Washington auf
beide Seite das Kongress ist die
Demokraten und die re publikaner lassen
Sie uns noch ein bisschen stärker auf
die chinesische Seite blicken weil
einerseits stehen diese
Waffenlieferungen im Raum andererseits
gab es diesen 12 Punkte planen seitens
Peking in dem beide Seiten ja zu
Verhandlungen aufgerufen wurden wie muss
man sich das vorstellen welche Ziele
verfolgt Peking in diesem Krieg schon
gemacht der
der Krieg dem Pudding angefangen hatte
mit der Ukraine
haben nicht in der dieselbe überrascht
das ist eine schöne Gerüchte das
[Musik]
sich vereinbart haben auf einer
Freundschaft ohne Grenze vor dem
Olympia winterspiel im Päckchen da
gibt's natürlich einen Abkommen zwischen
beiden Seiten was
putinunterzeichnet haben aber in diese
24 Artikel gibt's nie wo wo eine eine
Formulierung im Sinne von Freundschaften
ohne Grenzen
derjenige des zweiten Mann das
Außenministeriums der bei einem Vortrag
diese Inter diese diesen Abkommen
introvertierte hat mit dem Begriff
Freundschaften ohne Grenze wurde gemacht
hat
von Außenminister
sozusagen entfernt unter dem Mann ist
jetzt diese zweite Mal von
Kulturminister also für Tourismus es ist
ein pro-russische
die problemat aber offensichtlich hatte
selber falsch verstanden
ich glaube die Chinesen selber verstehen
solche Sachen Verlierer von dem Krieg ah
putinhaltepuzzi mir offensichtlich nicht
offen gesagt hatte dass er ganze Ukraine
angreifen möchte
im Februar 2021 und zweitens ist Jena
hatte Ukraine verloren in der Tat wo
kein jung war ein vier ähm aktiver
Korbacher Türe Medizinerin darum geht um
mich chinesische
Industriepolitik Militärtechnologie
neue Seidenstraße Initiative
Drehscheibe für agrarwirtschaftliche
Produktion
Sprungbrett nach Europa das heißt ihre
These ist China kann das was da gerade
passiert auch nicht noch schlimmer ist
noch schlimmer sie haben dich Jesus
vertrauen der Europäer verloren das ist
eine eine riesengroße Problem für die
für dich in der deswegen könnte ich
verstehen und was will China unternehmen
um dieses Vertrauen wieder genau
angefangen eine ähm offensiv
zu initiieren der neue Botschafter in
Größe der hatte vorgeschlagen der wir
sollten unsere gescheiterte oder
eingefrorene
universitätsabkommen weder Berlin der
hat vorgeschlagen wir schlagen vor
Europa europäische gleichzeitig Sanktion
fallen lassen und dann wieder beginnen
schon angekommen
nachher weggehen dass er zusammen mit
Scholz im genau
es war auch ein Punkt dass er Wind wurde
als ein Zeichen der der die Sense
zwischen Paris und Berlin damals ich
glaube es gab viele anderen Streitpunkte
in der Fall war das mehr so Agenda mäßig
nicht also Zeit zu organisieren ein
bisschen kompliziert aber stimmt also
ich glaube es gibt diese berühmte Satz
dass Europa jetzt momentan einen
Pflanzenfresser ist in einer Welt voller
Fleischfresser und jetzt ist die Frage
ist China ein Fleischfresser ist
Russland ein falschfresser ich glaube
für Russland ist die Antwort die ich
Frage schon beantwortet was ist mit der
USA und das haben sie völlig recht also
wenn das wenn wir zu einer
heißere Konfrontation kommen zwischen
die vereinigten standen Amerika und und
China
wo wir dann Europa stehen also bei der
Ukraine haben wir gesehen wie also die
Europäer haben sich voll und kannst
hinter der Amerikaner ausgerichtet und
zwar
beim jenen Mittel die Ukraine Elfen den
Krieg zu gewinnen oder den Krieg nicht
verlieren das kommt glaube ich in meine
Theorie ist wenn tatsächlich also ein
Konfliktes zwischen wash and the
besünden
würde automatisch Europa automatisch auf
der Seite der USA steht aber an der
Stelle sind wir nicht ich genau ich
glaube nur weil sie gerade gefragt haben
funktioniert eine Scham Offensive ich
glaube ehrlich gesagt die Zeiten sind so
ernst das für die Frage welchen Scham im
Moment chinesische Diplomaten und
Diplomaten spielen lassen die meisten
relativ unempfindlich sind auf der
Habenseite würde ich sagen hat China nur
einen Punkt vorzuweisen es ist die Reise
von Olaf Scholz nach Peking gewesen und
die Erklärung der chinesischen Staats
und Parteiführung dass der Einsatz und
das Drohnen mit nuklearen Waffen absolut
und zulässig und Verstoß gegen das
nuklearen Tabu ist übrigens das was ich
in dem sogenannten Friedensplan jetzt
auch noch mal wieder findet das ist
ohne Frage etwas was man hier in
Chinesen anrechnen kann aber wenn man
sich anguckt wie China in allen
internationalen Organisationen und zwar
nicht nur im UN-Sicherheitsrat sondern
auch in den vielen Untergruppierungen in
denen es heute um Getreidelieferungen
Menschenrechte in der Ukraine des
Verbreiten von Fake News und Lügen durch
die russische kann man nur sagen China
ist stets ein vergleichsweise treuer
Partner Russlands wenn es darum geht
wird etwas international verurteilt oder
aufgeklärt kann Russland sich in den
meisten Fällen darauf verlassen wie kaum
ein anderes Land China an seiner Seite
zu haben wenn ich noch einen zweiten
Punkt machen darf
wir reden ja jetzt seit Jahren über die
Frage wenn dieses große Land mit dieser
stolzen Tradition jetzt weniger nach
innen schaut sondern die weltpolitische
Bühne betritt wie verantwortungsvoll
wird es dann eigentlich agieren es ist
ja sagen wenn man das chinesische
Selbstbild des verantwortlich
Regierenden auf der aufsteigenden
Supermarkt würde ich sagen wir haben die
Ukraine erlebt wir haben aber auch
gerade die corona-krise erlebt wo die
Tatsache dass wir bis heute nicht wissen
was eigentlich genau passiert ist und
dass diese Frage so sehr politisiert
werden kann einzig und allein daran
liegt dass China bestehende
Verpflichtung nach den internationalen
Gesundheitsvorschriften einfach seit
Jahren
ignoriert und seiner Verpflichtung eine
Aufklärung zu einer Aufklärung
beizutragen nicht nachkommen also ich
würde sagen Punkte die nach wie vor das
chinesisch-amerikanische Verhältnis
belasten unter anderem natürlich auch
der Vorfall mit dem spionageballon alles
Dinge weswegen die Stimmung gegen China
wenn man das so sagen kann in Amerika
wirklich eine auch noch andere ist als
in Europa aber vor der Mitte ja es ist
sehr oberparteilich dass die Position
das China die große Herausforderung ist
für die USA und für die ähm
demokratische Bundesheer aber was
Professor gut gesagt hat ich glaube
schon dass am Anfang war China besorgt
über diese Krieg gegen Ukraine war für
China ist Stabilität wahrscheinlich auch
sehr wichtig aber auf der anderen Seite
ich denke es gibt vielleicht ein Kost
Verlust Analyse jetzt oder cos benefit
Analyse jetzt zu sehr sehen ja aber
diese Krieg ist könnte auch für uns ein
Vorteil sein weil das bringt dieser Idee
von dieser westliche Hegemonie runter
wie lange kann die wessen oder die
demokratische Länder zusammenstehen
gegenüber Ukraine und China möchte
Stabilität aber nicht laut dieser Regel
basierte System sie haben ein andere
Ideen über Menschenrechte und Philosoph
influence zum Beispiel oder andere
verhandel und deshalb ist Ukraine
wahrscheinlich nicht schön und sie das
ist wichtig dass ähm china hat gesagt
dass man sollte diese Nuklearwaffen
nicht als Bedrohung nutzen das war ein
Gewinn für Scholz aber ich denke
langfristig es wird schwierig China auf
so sozusagen aus treuliche Partner in
die da die haben verschiedene Seele also
die demokratische Länder die russische
Seele die Amerikaner haben amerikanische
Sehne dich deswegen ist ich glaube die
Erwartungen Europa aus
China wäre nur eine Partnerin das Land
alle unter Wünsche akzeptieren und so
sich agieren oder verhalten dann wäre
ich in einem Partner das ist eine
undifferenzierte dasstellung
schauen Sie mal dieses surfpunkteplan
dieser Event haben da sind ja eine
Mischung von verschiedener Ideen ohne
Vorstellungen
wo man versuchte Interesse von alle
Betroffene zusammen zu bringen das heißt
wenn die Europäer sagen okay ähm nur
gegen nukleare Waffen das ist wunderbar
aber die andere Punkte akzeptieren wir
nicht so deswegen keine Partner keine
glauben wir die Vermietung so wenn die
Chinesen tatsächlich nicht alle Dinge
Ideen von Europäer kann akzeptieren
werden dann wären sie auch keine Party
mehr für Russland deswegen putin hatte
das Programm diese 12 Punkteplan
abgenommen
Liebe Freund wunderbare Idee aber die
Bedingungen sind nicht reich weil wir
dumm war es nicht absolute erobert habe
und selensky ist ja jemanden dem wir
beseitigen möchten dies aber noch da ich
glaube dass das Problem ist die Chinesen
haben das Problem machen also sie können
Russland nicht fallen lassen
weil sie glauben hier ist noch ein vier
größere Spieler im Gang ist werde ich
lesen behaupten mindestens strategische
Vorstellung
die Strategie der USA ist jetzt Russland
und natürlich China jung und eine
Professur werfen aber sind sie das nicht
aber sie haben das die Angst wenn die
USA Rosen erledigt haben dann wäre das
nächste Ziel sofort hier ne das ist das
die die die der Verdacht und auch die
Befürchtung die Angst deswegen wollen
sie jetzt so so wie früher eine
friedenssituation hierbei schaffen so
dass es Konflikte sich nicht mehr
iskaliert sodass man reden können und
schon bevor ihr nach washing den
gereiste hat hatte ihn im Bundestag
geredet hatte erwähnt wo gerechte
Frieden er rede nicht mehr von Siege
Ukraine oder Sieger Russland so gerechte
Veränderungen wäre eine Situation wozu
wo ukrainings legitima Interesse an
territoriale integrierte und auch
Russland ist sicher die Interesse
garantiert werden dann wäre eine
gerechte Frieden nicht einseitig und das
ist aber die die europäische akzeptieren
das nicht man glauben ist No Go ist eine
Ausrede da die Chinesen sagen nein dass
ich daran Ausrede dass ich seine
legitime sich hat sie Interesse und das
muss man beruhigen ist das ja genau der
Punkt über den wir heute auch sprechen
das ist um die Idee geht wer ist
tatsächlich die Welt macht ist das die
sind das die USA ist das in dem Moment
Regina und genau dieser Konflikt spielt
sich ja mehr und mehr jetzt in diesen
Krieg rein was ja tatsächlich noch zu
einer weiteren Verschärfung führen kann
ist das so teilen Sie das was gut sagt
dass man aus europäischer Sicht zu viel
fordert also ich glaube wenn man guckt
die Wetter von Putin das
westbündnis mit der NATO die explodieren
könnte durch diesen Krieg ist verloren
aber hat irgendwas sehr gut gemacht und
zwar diesen Konflikt hat er einfach so
so um transformiert dass das jetzt so
eine Konflikt zwischen Russland ist
jetzt nicht im Krieg gegen die Ukraine
sondern gegen den Westen und da ist die
Frage wo positioniert
sich auch den anderen Kontinenten der
Welt Stichwort Brasilien Afrika also
diese Tournee in Afrika für macron ist
sehr wichtig aber auch hier also sehen
wir auch in Europa innerhalb von unsere
europäische Demokratie kursiert auch
dieses narrativ das eigentlich es ist
ein Krieg zwischen den besser und
Russland und USA ist auch sowieso schon
beteiligt und wir auch also Manifest für
Frieden also wenn man in der Demo in
Berlin war letzte Woche hat man so viel
gehört dass die USA eigentlich auch
Kriegsverbrecher sind in der Ukraine
indirekt und jetzt das haben wir auch in
Frankreich in der politische Diskussion
also große Unterstützung
an diese Position dass man eigentlich
wir Europäer oder wir West lernen nicht
so ganz unschuldig sind sie diese ganzen
Situation deshalb muss man auch ganz
genau sehen
durch diese diese
Neuorganisation der
konfrontationsdiskurs also wo stehen wir
und es hat ist es für mich
Französin aber auch europäen natürlich
zu große Sorge wo stehen wir ganz genau
wo wollen wir auch stehen wir Europäer
wir sind momentan nicht in der Lage und
selber zu verteidigen dann sehen wir da
in Ukraine wenn wir den Unterstützung
von Amerika nicht hätten wäre dann die
eine tanzvolle andere Situation in der
Ukraine wir brauchen dringend eine
strategisches Denken gemeinsam und auch
ja wäre dann eine heißere Konfrontation
mit China wo stehen wir momentan ist es
sofort mit der USA das ist klar aber
wollen wir also die Position Frankreich
ist immer so aufpassen nicht sofort an
schlecht zu China entwickeln wie wir
früher mit Russland hatte aber auch
nicht sofort direkt mit der USA also das
ist jetzt klare Diskurs von Paris immer
so sagen
die Souveränität Europa aber die Frage
ist wollen wir die und wie machen wir
die gibt's diese Unklarheit in dem
strategischen Denken in Europa sowie
voll cool das gerade geschildert hat
also Europa war jedenfalls im
strategischen Denken die gut aber ich
weiß auch gar nicht woher die
Erwartungen kommt dass nachdem wir uns
heute sogar die Frage stellen müssen ob
der Kalte Krieg eigentlich je zu Ende
gegangen ist oder ob wir nur so eine Art
Abschwung erlebt haben oder ob wir jetzt
in einem neuen Kalten Krieg sind bin ich
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht überrascht
dass keine fertige europäische Strategie
gibt aber ich finde wir können anfangen
die Frage zu beantworten die ja die
wichtigste ist diese gerade gestellt
haben wo stehen wir eigentlich so wo
stehen wir eigentlich auch im Verhältnis
zum Rest der Welt da finde ich haben wir
inzwischen sogar kannst ein paar ganz
gute Antworten da gibt sie Brasilianer
die in der irgendwie viele andere die
sagen mensch ihr im Westen seid schon
auch ein bisschen komisch in der Frage
für welche kriegerischen Konflikte und
Kriege interessiert ihr euch welche
ignoriert ihr eigentlich oder halten Sie
uns ein Stück den Spiegel vor und
ehrlich gesagt an mancher Stelle
irgendwie auch zu Recht sie sagen ihr
seid reiche Gesellschaft und seit in der
Lage hohe Energiekosten beispielsweise
auszugleichen wir können es nicht das
heißt wir wir laufen an bestimmten
Stellen haben wir es mit Problemen zu
tun um mit Schwierigkeiten für die wir
in der Vergangenheit vielleicht
irgendwie auch ein Stück irgendwie zu
blind gewesen denn da haben wir mit
unseren eigenen Widersprüchlichkeiten zu
tun aber am Ende bleibt doch ehrlich
gesagt eins wir erleben hier
einen brutalen Krieg und wir sehen dass
es zwei Länder gibt die im ersten kalten
Krieg übrigens noch eher Gegner gewesen
sind und China entscheidet sich
auf die Seite der Unfreiheit zu wechseln
der Unverantwortlichkeit ich glaube dass
wir lange Zeit vergessen haben dass
China im Kerne kommunistische Diktatur
geblieben ist als der wenigen Länder die
sich im Jahr 1989 schon entschieden
haben
Freiheitsbewegungen wie wir sie denn
überall im Ostblock gesehen haben mit
Panzer niederzuschlagen und das ist im
Kern gleich geblieben und daran wird
sich auch nichts ändern wenn man auf all
unsere Widersprüchlichkeiten und Fehler
verweist dass die entscheidende Frage
für China eigentlich sein wird in einer
solchen Auseinandersetzung hält man sich
damit auf den Westen
mit seinen eigenen Fehlern und
Widersprüchlichkeiten zu konfrontieren
das kann man machen aber es befreit
nicht davon selbst verantwortliche
verantwortliche Position einzunehmen und
die kann ich nicht sehen und ich glaube
wenn China das nicht tun wird dann wird
jedenfalls die Entscheidung Europas eine
ganz einfache sagen nämlich dass die
Regierung und die Menschen auf China in
Zukunft anders schauen werden und sagen
werden da gibt es ein faszinierenden
wirtschaftlichen Aufstieg aber es ist
ein Land das unglücklicherweise von den
Werten an die wir glauben und glauben
sollten davon irgendwie nichts trägt
weil sie Euro
Werte diese vertreten sollen die
Chinesen übernehmen das wollen sie nicht
teilweise das Problem ist also
China natürlich bleibt natürlich ein
autoritärsystem
[Musik]
versucht eine Dritten Welt zu finden
zwischen tadison in der kommissionische
Weg dann ist sicher weg ohne modernere
westliche weg also diese beide
alternative Hunde nicht haben was ist
ein totale ganz andere Weg ich glaube
die Zukunft
von Finalität
Überwachung starte und es ist aber das
ist falsch verstehen ich beobachtete
dieser empirisch wenn Sie daran denken
pro Jahr vor der Corona
100 Millionen Chinesen mittelständische
ohne Familie Kinder
raus nach Europa USA Tourismus machen
und dann freiwillig nach Hause gegangen
sind keine einzige der gerne hier
bleiben möchte da muss man sagen was ist
da los das System tatsächlich
wieso wurden die Chinesen so viele
Einkaufen Urlaub verbringen und am
Freitag nach Hause das gibt auch die
Logik das Systems das heißt also die
Chinesen Türken ganz anderes wie ähm
meine Kollegen hier gesagt hatte die
haben eigene Seele und deswegen haben
genau dieses Wirtschaftswachstum das ist
ja jetzt deutlich geringer es liegt
glaube ich jetzt bei 5,5 % wenn ich das
richtige für die Prognose habe
2020 nur drei Prozent genau natürlich
auch wegen Corona
das ist ja genau die Situation die
anders ist als im Kalten Krieg die sie
eben angesprochen haben die Wirtschaften
sind so verpflichtet
und wir haben diese globalisierte
Wirtschaft ist das etwas was genau in
dieser Situation jetzt hilfreich sein
kann wie gesagt was Professor gesagt hat
ist alles im guten schon für die
Chinesen aber das Problem ist wenn China
nicht hilfsbereit ist im Kampf von der
Kurve Pandemie oder in Klima and
Veränderung oder total one dann ist es
ein Problem für uns alle und dann ist
ähm den Kurs von China kann man nicht
akzeptieren oder muss man ein Freund
gegenüber stark bleiben und zurück
zurück was an Frau gesagt hat über
Europa und strategisches Denken ich
denke die USA möchte eine starke Europa
das ist gut für die transformatische
Beziehung das ist gut für die USA aber
ich glaube diese Frage kann man ewig
warten es gibt keine strategisches
Denken in Europa zur Zeit und dafür
leider sind die Beziehung zwischen Paris
und Berlin und Berlin und Warschau nicht
positiv genug oder stark genug zur Zeit
und deshalb der Faktor bleibt die USA
Führungskraft in Amerika was gar nicht
so schlimm ist ich denke die die Wünsche
ist nur das Europa ein bisschen mehr
handelsfähig agieren kann gemeinsam mit
den USA dass man investiert in den
militar Rüstung und nicht eine Trennung
zwischen Handelspolitik und
sicherheitspolitisch muss man eigentlich
zusammen nehmen diese diese geschlossen
hat die gefordert wird die fordert
Amerika natürlich jetzt auch gerade sehr
heraus mit diesem Inflation Redaktion
ist ja gerade Subventionen gibt weil in
Form von Steuererleichterung für die
Produktion von E-Autos wenn sie in
Amerika stattfindet und dadurch wird
natürlich ein wenig herausgefordert die
Einigkeit Europas weil jedes europäische
Land auf seine Art und Weise damit
umgehen muss und das ist ja auch ein
Punkt der zwischen Frankreich und
Deutschland nicht ganz das ist jetzt die
Frage wäre dann so eine Konfrontation
oder ein Krieg zwischen China und us
ich bin sehr also ich bin ich bin sehr
gespannt was würden die Europäer sagen
und nicht nur die europäische
Regierungen oder die europäische
Institution sondern auch die
Bevölkerungen also das hören wir schon
mal bei dem Krieg auf unsere Kontinent
ist viele sagen das ist doch nicht unser
Krieg ehrlich gesagt jetzt ist die Frage
würden die Europäer sagen ein Krieg
zwischen USA und und China ist das unser
Krieg und dann sieht man das ganz genau
also beiden sieht ganz klar also ähm
wenn es die Frage ist ich soll meine
Wirtschaft schützen gegen China z.B dann
hat er keine Gruppe das macht er ganz
klar und diese Inflation
also wurde in Paris zum Beispiel einfach
eine feindliche Antwort so betrachtet
und ich weiß dass Paris hat schon in
Oktober dazu viel diskutiert mit Berlin
und meinte wir brauchen eine sofortige
und starke europäische Antwort die jetzt
kommt aber viel verschwächtigt und auch
verteilt durch Europa also Europa hat
Moment
keine finanzierungskapazität auf diese
infashion Tradition hat zu antworten und
deshalb ist wenn wenn beiden und
irgendwelchen anderen Präsident in der
USA sagt für mich ist hauptsache ich bin
stark in China und wenn das die
europäische Wirtschaft kaputt macht ist
es mir eigentlich egal ist jetzt die
Frage wo ist denn dann Europa und ich
würde mich wünschen dass wir sagen wir
stehen aber der USA
ganz kurz in den USA gibt's auch ähm
Frage ob die Bevölkerung hinter die US
Regierung sein wird im Falle einer
Attacke gegenüber Taiwan wir haben immer
noch diese Pussy von Studie die
gegenüber
ty one aber mit Inflation reduction Act
die Europäer es tut mir leid haben ein
bisschen geschlafen in Deutschland
schlafen also das klar
waren vor Ort im Sommer in haben gesagt
ah das ist ein nackter für uns wir
müssen auch
Maßnahmen Regeln haben mit der ARD und
Europa hat nicht reagiert bist du zu
spät ist und ehrlich gesagt ich denke
ich sehe in Berlin die Grünen sind sehr
nonchalant oder nicht so besorgt darüber
die denken es ist gut dass die USA zu
jetzt Klimaziele und
Geschäftsziele
zusammenbringt und ich denke es gibt
Antworten vor Europa auch die Frage ist
kann man jetzt koordinieren innerhalb
Europa und dann
gegenüber verlangen was man will in
Washington ich denke das ist ein
bisschen also das Thema
Europa sagen meint dieses Land ja auch
ganz gerne Deutschland wir werden im
Zweifel weil wir exportorientiert sind
wird vor allem unser Maschinenbau sehr
davon profitieren von eben diesen Umbau
dem CO2 neutralen Umbau in den USA das
wird für Frankreich nicht im gleichen
ausmaßgeld aber mein Eindruck ist das
alle erkannt haben dass an dieser Stelle
jetzt einen Riss zwischen den USA und
Europa keine gute Idee ist und dem dient
ja wenn ich richtig sehe auch im
Wesentlichen die Reise der
kommissionspräsidentin nach Washington
aber sagen wir mal das grundlegende
Problem dass wir hier jetzt in diesem
Teil der Sendung diskutieren das wird ja
bleiben und es wird irgendwann die Frage
sein wer übernimmt Verantwortung und wer
übernimmt letztlich auch die ungeheuren
finanziellen Lasten die mit diesen Krieg
verbunden sind die übrigens auch mit
diesen Krieg noch verbunden sein werden
lange nachdem er hoffentlich irgendwann
den Ende gefunden haben wird und ich
glaube dass das schon absehbar sein wird
dass die amerikanische Position dann im
Zweifel sein wird zu sagen gut wir haben
hier jetzt noch mal in der Frage wie
militärisch zu einem Ende gekommen ist
haben wir uns auf eine ganz besondere
Art und Weise engagiert aber wenn es
jetzt um die Zukunft geht jenseits der
Sicherheit Garantien EU-Mitgliedschaft
wieder Aufbau all das was uns für
Jahrzehnte beschäftigen wird nehme ich
an dass die Position der USA sein das
ist jetzt mal eher eine europäische
Angelegenheit und an der Stelle sollten
wir uns nichts vormachen dann wird es
auch innerhalb Europas sehr
unterschiedliche Positionen geben die
man heute schon beobachten kann die von
einer sehr starken und klaren
Vorstellungen in Osteuropa reichen
Deutschland würde ich da eher in der
Mitte sehen aber je weiter man irgendwie
in Richtung Westen kommen muss man auch
da sagen wird es irgendwie also das
werden die die schwierigsten
Diskussionen werden die wir in den
kommenden Jahren zu führen haben zwei
die Amerikaner natürlich auch noch ein
Thema sehr viel stärker im Blick haben
als das in Europa ein Thema ist und das
ist der Konflikt mit Taiwan da ist es ja
so dass im Volkskongress heute gesagt
wurde man strebe in Peking eine
friedliche Wiedervereinigung an
gleichzeitig haben die Amerikaner diese
Woche bekannt gegeben Waffen im Wert von
knapp 600 Millionen Euro liefern zu
wollen Anteil waren
das ist ein Konflikt der natürlich jetzt
in dieser ohnehin schon sehr
herausfordernde Situation noch
zusätzlich kommt wie ihre Einschätzung
Spiels das darf man nicht getrennte
betrachtet unter ihnen dann im gesamten
Kontext ich glaube damals zu Frau kohrse
schöne Idee ich glaube die Frage wo
bleibt Europa ist immer Europa ist ja
für Gericht verpflichtet
sich auf die Seite der USA zu schlagen
wenn er seine Konflikte zwischen
Päckchen oder waschen ausbricht ohne
weiteres europa muss sofort aus meiner
ist verpflichtet USA zu unterstützen
nehmen wir zum Beispiel NATO Artikel 5
das heißt du hast keine andere Wahl
deswegen ist es eigentlich besser für
alle Seite das kein kriege keine Karte
kriege keine heiße Kriege zwischen
waschen denn ohne Peking ausbrechen
würde das wurden die Chinesen nicht
dem Grund das auch nicht aber die die
geopolitische die Spiele also die haben
Eigendynamik entwickelt im Blick auf
Taiwan zum Beispiel
Taiwan Frage ist auch nicht nur also wir
erinnern uns steht aus ihrer Sicht da
jetzt eine militärische
Auseinandersetzung bevor
das ist eine
amerikanische Freunde spielen sehr gerne
taubank
das Nervensystem der Chinesen ich kann
dich Chinesen einfacher mit ein paar
Milliarden Euro oder US Dollar
Waffenlieferung steht oder das sehende
West sind wenn sie die die
Interaktionsprozess will ich genau 20
Jahre beobacht haben der der muss war
immer so
Bewegung verstärkt sich in Taiwan
Unterstützung von USA in verschiedenen
Formen Aufwertung der Beziehung waren
militärische Lieferung Waffensystem dann
massive militärische Übung USA
Abschreckung das heißt abschreckend
Seite Jahren diese strategiephilosophie
Siege ohne Krieg das ist es das höchste
Priorität philosophisch angedacht
überlieferte Strategie von der Chinesin
dieser Kampf liegt zu lösen aber ohne da
mehr eigene Landsleute zu vernichten
auch teilbar wunderbar
weil sie glauben
die Seite ist auf unsere Seite müssen
wir uns nicht beeilen das ist die auch
funktionierendes zweimal angedeutet die
Seite wir haben die zweite unter der
Dynamik die ist aber unsere Seite wir
können auch lange warten wir haben 70
Jahre lang gewartet wieso können wir
nicht machen
dass die Zeit genau auf der anderen
Seite ist und das ehrlich gesagt Taiwan
ja zu einer immer reiferin Demokratie
heranwächst in der es Menschen gibt die
sich entscheiden eben nicht so leben zu
wollen wie man in einer Diktatur leben
muss deswegen würde ich sagen mit der
Zeit schauen wir mal wie es ausgeht dass
die militärische Frage angeht das
schätze ich so ein wie Sie ich glaube
dass die chinesische Seite im Moment
auch den Krieg in der Ukraine ganz genau
verfolgt und sich auch die Frage wie
überlegen eigentlich vermeintlich das
eigene Militär sei wenn man versuchen
würde Taiwan einzunehmen sich
möglicherweise irgendwie noch mal neu
stellt und sich auch noch mal die Frage
neu stellt ob man vielleicht die eigenen
Möglichkeiten nicht irgendwie ein Stück
überschätzt ich will nur einen Punkt
verweisen der glaube ich in der
amerikanischen Diskussion wichtig ist
und bei uns auch nicht richtig
angekommen ist die Frage wie das
Schicksal teilbar uns ist sollten wir
jetzt nicht alleine unter dem
Gesichtspunkt betrachten ob es zu einer
Inversion kommt oder nicht sondern das
was wir in den Vergangenheit ja auch
schon erlebt haben russisches
aggressives Verhalten gegenüber der
Ukraine beispielsweise das auch lange
schon begonnen hatte bevorzugen im Krieg
haben und das kann aus ökonomischer
Heizung bestehen aus
destabilisierungsmaßnahmen aus
Cyberangriffen und all diese Dinge sehen
wir sehr wohl im Verhältnis zwischen
China und Taiwan also ich würde davor
waren jetzt immer nur darauf zu schauen
ob es da jetzt eigentlich zu einem
großen Krieg kommt sondern dass wir auch
schauen welche Mittelschiene eigentlich
heute schon einsetzen vielleicht in den
kommenden Jahren einsetzt um zu einer
würde ich mal sagen eine Lösung zu
kommen von der ich jedenfalls nicht
sagen würde dass sie dann noch friedlich
ist sie ist dann vielleicht kein großer
Krieg aber eine friedliche
Wiedervereinigung
aus meiner Sicht ist die Mentalität
Russland nicht die differenzierte genug
zu bedacht sondern die beiden Akteure
als eins zu eins zu betrachten
auf die Punkte zu achten die man
möglicherweise im Zusammenspiel mit
Russland jahrelang zu sehr
ignoriert hat also gerade Mittel eben
nicht von sondern andere die Hose die
Erfahrung mit der Russland kann man
nicht automatisch übertragen auf auf die
Frage wie immer umgeht wenn man das so
macht ist eine methodische falsche weg
davon ausgehen Russland
identisch wäre das ist ja nicht so ich
meine das nicht getan zu haben also
hier weil sie immer argumentieren
gemacht deswegen aufpassen dass ich
Chinesen auch da so machen würde und das
ist zu vereinfacht ne also dies ist eine
eine Kapitulation sozusagen ein eine
aufführen von eigener seiner
intelligente neue Ideen zur um die
Chinesen besser mit Chinesen zu gehen
das ist der Punkt
Gewalt
ob sie aus Russland aus China
haben keine Gewalt
er hatte Friedensplan initiiert aber
trotzdem das gibt's jetzt bleibt weil
man wie wie vorhin überhaupt das Problem
befindet sich in dem Kopf das muss man
muss man auflösen
pragmatisch mit den Chinesen umgehen das
ist meine meine
versucht zu machen weil drei Jahrzehnte
jetzt das war das war ich denke man hat
versucht China in der
in der nicht genau
kann ein sehr pragmatischer und
produktive Partner sein verschiedene
Hinsichten und man hat versucht China
die offene Hand zu geben über die Jahren
aber ich denke jetzt man ist so ein
Punkt gekommen mehr Skepsis gegenüber
China zu machen auf unsere eigene
Interesse und für unsere eigene
Sicherheit in der Zukunft genauso zudem
ja Fragen gibt es auch zuschauerfranken
wir sind in der letzten Viertelstunde
unserer Sendung und die gehört den
Zuhörerinnen und Zuschauern in dem Punkt
und wir hören mal was Ralf
Patz aus Aalen in Westfalen für eine
Frage hat guten Morgen
tanzt die Optimist ja
wir hören sie gut
ich teile nicht so ganz die
optimistische Einstellung dass China
nicht auf eine lange auf ein
Konfliktpotential hinausläuft im ohne
diesen Konflikt mit der Ukraine zu
versimplizieren denke ich dass es für
China eine Blaupause ist um genau zu
beobachten wie reagiert der Rest der
Welt im Falle von einer Aggression und
soweit ist wie möglich ist verfolge ich
ähm chinesische Medien und daraus geht
für mich ganz klar hervor China tut was
es sagt und es sagt seit geraumer Zeit
in aller Deutlichkeit das ist seine
Interessen verfolgt um an die Spitze der
Welt zu gelangen unter Einsatz
militärischer Mittel insbesondere Taiwan
einzunehmen meine Frage sind wir nicht
naiv haben wir nicht ein Fehler begangen
dadurch dass wir jetzt einen Konzept
vermissen lassen um China eine klare
Antwort von ihm vornherein zu geben dass
ein Konfliktpotenzial von in China
heruntergebrochen zu einer globalen
Katastrophe führen würde ich sehe eine
große Gefahr in das was im Pazifik
passiert als das was wir jetzt in Europa
zu bewältigen versuchen vielen Dank
danke das ist genau die Frage die wir ja
auch schon ein wenig am Tisch diskutiert
hatten ich glaube aber der Zuschauer
möchte noch mal eine Antwort ja ich
verstehe das natürlich ja wie gesagt ich
ist wir haben trotzdem die Auffassung
dass es
keine Krieg ausbrechen würde inzwischen
China und Taiwan indem das China
angreifen würde das schauen Sie mal die
Bewegungen in der letzten zwei drei
Monate nach Dezember die Chinesen haben
sie auch angefangen mit äh
Oppositionsgruppe Taiwans zu verhandeln
haben sie massenhafte Delegation
eingeladen das hatte man hier in Europa
gar nicht gesehen die die europäischen
Partei die die das war früher mit der
Chinesin Bürgerkriege geführt haben da
waren verloren
haben jetzt
baute Päckchen auf solche Leute
weil sie pro Wiedervereinigung sind im
Jahr 2024 kam der präsidenziale war
pitchen Seester Hoffnung auf diese
Kräfte wenn sie an die Macht und
gekommen wäre dann kann man mit ihnen
verhandeln das ist die Hoffnung man hat
einmal versuchte Hilfe vor wenigen
Jahren gescheitert jetzt kommen wir
wieder diese Initiative
glaube ich ein bisschen bleibe ich
optimistisch aber die Bedenken die der
Kollegen gerade geschwommen haben
natürlich die sachliche Team und wir
hören mal was Siegfried geißbauer aus
Karlsruhe eine Freiheit guten Morgen
hallo können sie gut hören ja genau
wunderbar also meine Frage ist immer der
mich selbst schuld für diese ganzen
Konflikte wann wird wir Westen nicht zu
gierig nach dem Fall der Mauer die die
Russland und China sozusagen reich zu
machen wir haben China die ganzen
Produkte genommen was sie produziert
haben für besten wir haben die
Technologie nach Ostern gebracht also
sprich hinter den ich selber schuld dass
sie so reich geworden sind um solche
Kriege zu führen oder solche Dinge auch
zu machen sind wäre es dann nicht
möglich sozusagen den Chinesen und den
Russen zu sagen auf sonst machen wir
eine wirtschaftliche Blockade und zwar
nicht nur wie jetzt so eine ganz
komplett
ja wer mag den Zuschauer Antworten in
dieser Frage haben wir ja in meine ich
ich glaube wir waren bestimmt naiv über
die Jahre aber wir haben auch selbst
profitiert ich meine die
Handelsbeziehung zwischen die Uhr
zwischen USA und China ist auch sehr
groß und ehrlich gesagt ich kann nicht
glauben dass wir wollen sofort die
Couponing machen wie niemand sagt das
man muss nur sagen man muss kritisch
gegenüber und aufpassen und strategisch
denken weil es ist nicht ein Partner wie
Deutschland oder Frankreich und
Präsident beiden und auch Chance denken
es gibt ein sozusagen ein Skizzen oder
ein Drift in der Welt zwischen Otter
kreativ und der Magie oder kann man auch
sagen zwischen Freiheit und Germany habe
ich auch gehört dass es vielleicht eine
bessere Beschreibung und man spielt ein
bisschen mit Feuer wenn man so tief
Handelsbeziehungen mit
Autokraten unterwegs ist ja aber ich
glaube da ist die Linie gerade zu
perfekt beschrieben aber wenn man es
wird jetzt kein vor allem die
wirtschaftlichen Verbindung zu China
sind auch in diesem Land so groß oder
auch in den USA dass niemanden in die
Kappeln will aber auf der anderen Seite
wird es sicher auch kein zurückgeben in
eine Zeit die wir auch gesehen haben ist
für die Frage
wie verhält sich ein Land auf
internationaler Bühne und die Frage wie
sind eigentlich die sonstigen
Beziehungen vor allem die
wirtschaftsbeziehung dass wir das mehr
oder weniger voneinander trennen das
wird es nicht geben und da bleibe ich
irgendwie bei meinem Punkt ich glaube
die Betrachtung auch viele europäische
Regierung und auch der Menschen in
Europa wird sich verändern was immer die
chinesische Denkweise ist wenn die
chinesische Denkweise nicht erlaubt
einmal den klaren Satz zu sagen dass der
Überfall Russland auf die Ukraine
völkerrechtswidrig ist dass er irgendwie
enden muss und dass die Frage dass wir
eine
regelbasierte Ordnung haben bei allen
Macken und Ecken die sie so hat auf die
wir uns eigentlich geeinigt haben
die China übrigens auch immer propagiert
aber wenn es dann eine politische
Führung ist die unmöglich ist diesen
relativ einfachen Satz zu sagen aus
welchen Gründen auch immer ich will
nicht Russland mit jeder vergleichen
aber wenn Sie diesen Satz irgendwie
nicht sagen kann dann würde ich sagen
können ja die Europäer und europäische
Regierung auch gar nicht anders als es
als das zu nehmen irgendwie was es ist
nämlich das China in der Frage wie es
bis hin zu auf solche großen Konflikte
schaut und sich verhält einfach ein
Schwert zu berechnen da um nicht zu
sagen unberechenbarer Partner ist und
das wird Auswirkungen haben noch meine
Überzeugung danke dafür und das ist auch
das Thema die Zuschauer glaube ich am
meisten umtreibt Johanna Holm in
Augsburg
Frau holen ja ihre Frage gerne in die
Runde guten Tag zusammen ich habe eine
Frage und zwar ich Sie Tina eigentlich
eine ganz andere Rolle und zwar ich sehe
China so jetzt
das China er die Weltwirtschaft macht
Nummer eins werden will und eigentlich
ein kriegen weniger interessiert ist
also ich meine sie müssen sich natürlich
ein aber ich sehe Chinesen in diese
Richtung er und jetzt die Frage
vielleicht an den Herrn Professor
darf ich ja ich glaube die Beobachtung
teile ich ja auch immer also was die
Chinesen haben möchte oder erreichen
möchte ist in der Tat so gut zu leben
wie die amerikane wie die Europäer
Punkte fertig aber sie wurde an andere
winkelkind der Weggefährten unser
amerikanische europäischer Freunde nicht
das ist dann auch ein autoritäre total
den kollektive
besehnte welke wo er Idealismus keine
Rolle
Individualismus nur sekundäre Rolle
spielt kollektive Interesse brechen
private individuelle Interesse und das
begründet auch natürlich die Repression
und auch Unterdrückung Überwachung alles
das ist der der Punkte ist die Chinesen
wurden wie der andere Kollegen auch
gefragt hatte die wohnen die sich wohnen
auch an der Spitze sein genau sogar auch
die USA überholen
die Frage ist ist das legitime Interesse
dass ein großes Land der mit 1,4
Milliarden Menschen das hier zu
erreichen oder muss man das Blockieren
regelmäßigen ja aber wer formuliert die
Regel das ist die Frage kann man die
Chinesen haben vorgeschlagen die Regel
die sie von dir haben vor 70 Jahren
haben die akzeptiert wir sind dabei
getreten WTO Dublin Theo und auch wird
Banken internation Währungsreform ist
alles wieder dabei
darf ich fragen darf
an den beiden Punkten die wir heute
morgen diskutiert haben überall auf die
Ukraine oder Einhaltung der
internationalen Gesundheitsvorschriften
um aufzuklären woher das Coronavirus
kommt beruht irgendwie jeweils auf
Regelungen die die China unterschrieben
hat diese Nachricht ich finde das
Garantie ich finde das an der Stelle
eine relativ einfache Frage ist man sagt
der gibt es Verpflichtung und
Vereinbarung auf die man auf die man
sich vereinbart hat China auch und
werden die eingehalten oder Kinder auch
nicht dass das eine individuelle Frage
innerhalb Chinas ist sondern es ist eine
Frage die uns alle alle Menschen
außerordentliche irgendwie beschäftigen
deswegen kurz herr Frank in Friedberg
bei Augsburg guten Morgen guten Tag ich
hätte gerne eine Beobachtung geteilt und
in der Statement von den Herrn Damen
bekommen ich bin weltweit unterwegs
gewesen und ich denke ich habe sehr viel
Kulturen kennengelernt mir fällt auf
dass der Respekt der gegenseitige auch
vor den Staaten voreinander eigentlich
unter die Rede gekommen ist und das
ganze in Europa zumindest mit dem
entweder exorbitanten Naivität gegenüber
Russland und China ergänzt worden ist
ich meine hier bloß Schröder Gabriel den
KUKA die den Augsburger schnell eine
komplett Katastrophe hier wurde
natürlich nicht nur die Robotertechnik
sondern auch neue Techniker und China
verkauft die gesamte kanonensteuerung
des Leopard 2 ist schon längst in China
bekannt und ich finde das hier einfach
dringend Realität Realismus und eine
klare Begrenzung auf eigene claims und
und Grenzen
angeraten ist natürlich ist der Krieg in
Russland gegen Ukraine führt absolut zu
verdammen und ich meine dass die
Weltgemeinschaft hier noch viel stärker
Russland in die Schranken weisen müsste
inklusive China natürlich so und wie
gesagt also ich denke das auch die Zeit
eben das hegemonismus endgültig zu Ende
ja danke für Ihre Frage und das ist auch
was Sie gesagt haben also und das hat so
weh als sie gesagt haben haben wir einen
strategisches Denken in Europa in Paris
Berlin Warschau haben wir nicht und
deshalb sind wir Europäer der Pflichten
amerikanischen Alliierten folgen und
deshalb ja
wir waren naiv
wie Europa haben auch gedacht das ist
die Ende der Geschichte alles Gute wir
leben in einem friedliche Welt und wir
können mit putinen handeln und wir
können mit China auch machen und jetzt
ist diese Zeit jetzt zu Ende und deshalb
ist es umso dringend dass wir
momentan binifizieren wir haben hier
immer noch diese diese Schutz von der
USA und da sehen wir jetzt aber wie
lange noch das ist es gibt ein Momentum
jetzt momentan ein nato-momentum oder
ein
westbündnis Momentum in Europa aber wie
sollten von diesem Moment profitieren um
richtig mal
die Folge zu bauen und zu gucken was
wollen wir und was sind auch unsere
Werte wie schützen diese Werte und
unsere auch unsere Interesse auch die
wirtschaftliche Interesse und deshalb
glaube ich schon das müsste also
nächstes Jahr sind die europäische
Wahlen äh hier und da sollte auf jeden
Fall ein Kernpunkt sein dass wir alle
zusammen diskutieren wollen weil wenn
wir zusammen diskutieren so sind wir
auch glaubwürdig auf der internationale
Ebene danke dafür und wir hören Herrn
Hussmann aus ostbevern
guten Tag guten Tag
also es fällt mir äußerst schwer dem
Herrn von der deutschen Zeitung zu hören
im Grunde genommen ist er ein sprechter
des der Interessen der US amerikanischen
Imperialisten
die USA haben in den vergangenen über
150 Jahren über 120 Jahre im
Kriegszustand mit einem anderen Land
sich befunden ich frage mich über welche
Weltordnung sprechen wir hier das was
verteidigen sie hier es ist doch
eindeutig dass die USA
Russland
provoziert haben
okay dann kurze Antwort gerne noch
schade dass wir nicht länger reden
können weil ich ganz anderer Meinung bin
als sie ich glaube dass ich ein halbes
Berufsleben damit beschäftigt habe mich
mit den Schwächen unseres eigenen
Systems und übrigens auch mit den
Fehlern der USA die man absolut
kritisieren kann zu beschäftigen aber
ich finde ich komme mit ihrer
Gleichsetzung nicht zurecht weil ich
glaube dass die USA in dieser Frage
nichts damit zu tun hat das Russland die
Ukraine
überfallen hat über vieles kann man
reden aber auch dass man über Fehler
reden kann und muss die der besten
gemacht hat nach dem Ende des Kalten
Krieges darüber ist übrigens in den USA
viel mehr debattiert worden als bei uns
hier in Deutschland und trotzdem
halte ihre Gleichsetzung für falsch
dann ist das der Moment wo wir leider
nicht noch eine weitere Zuschauerfrage
schaffen werden aber ich bedanke mich
bei Ihnen für die Diskussion hier am
Morgen im internationalen Frühschoppen
und wir alle wünschen Ihnen jetzt noch
einen schönen Sonntag und Grüßen aus
Köln danke schön
[Musik]